Apple's iPad Pro is about to get its
biggest update since 2018 with massive
upgrades that you definitely are going
to want to wait for including a full
redesign a 13-inch display side upgrade
that hasn't happened in the history of
the iPad Pro a brand new updated magic
keyboard and a brand new secret feature
that nobody is expecting so in this
video I'm gonna go through and explain
all the new features as well as a bunch
of Apple patents that hint at this brand
new awesome secret feature so let's get
started according to Mark German on his
power on newsletter this past weekend
the iPad Pro is ready for a big update
next year which I believe is gonna
happen in either March or April he
mentioned that while the current iPad
Pro has seen some common upgrades to the
chip the cameras display Tech and
sensors in recent years it has hasn't
undergone more fundamental changes so
next year it's getting a full on
overhaul one of the bigger changes will
be the new M3 chip which is supposed to
be built on tsmc's new three nanometer
chip technology that'll make it much
faster and more efficient but the
biggest standout feature that everyone
is going to be talking about is the new
OLED display which is gonna likely be
the best tablet display ever made the
current 12.9 inch iPad Pro Model uses a
really good mini LED display with
excellent contrast colors and an
incredible 1600 nits of brightness for
viewing HDR content the only problem is
that It suffers from this glowing halo
effect that you can see when the lights
are dimmed down low now the big deal is
that next year the M3 iPad Pro is
getting a new OLED display that will fix
that issue by using two OLED display
panels stacked in tandem which means
that you get all the benefits of
individual LEDs with no halo effect but
the brightness literally gets doubled
because they're using two of them so
these hybrid OLED displays might even go
up to a matching 1600 nits of brightness
which is basically a first for OLED
tablet displays because they're usually
quite dim making these new displays the
best in the world and the even better
part is that the current 11 inch iPad
Pro Models didn't even get upgraded to
the mini LED display that the 12.9 inch
model got so it still uses the old LCD
display so it's going to be a huge
upgrade for that model but even better
for the first time ever the larger iPad
Pro size will now have a 13 inch display
which represents a small 0.1 inch boost
for that model and the 11 inch is going
to go up to 11.1 inches now you might
not understand the main point of that
difference but I believe that apple is
working on making the display bezels
even thinner just like they're doing for
the iPhone 15 Pro Models this year which
will give you a bigger display size
within the same chassis size and on top
of that there's a pretty good chance
that with the OLED display Tech apple is
going to give us an always-on display on
the iPad Pro just like they have on the
current iPhone 14 Pro Models this year
but now with all of that out of the way
let's jump in to the major secret
feature that I believe is going to be on
the 2024 iPad Pro over two years ago in
June of 2021 Mark German and Debbie woo
from Bloomberg said that Apple was
working on an iPad Pro with wireless
charging and reverse wireless charging
to charge other products like the iPhone
airpods case and maybe even the Apple
watch it was said that Apple would be
switching to a full glass back in order
to support the wireless charging coils
since it doesn't work with metal backs
and some other rumors also mentioned
Apple potentially just using a larger
glass Apple logo instead of making the
whole back glass to kind of make it more
shatter resistant but as it turned out
in 2022 Apple's M2 iPad Pro update was
extremely boring with no real updates
apart from the M2 Chip so I fully
believe that Apple delayed the launch of
their big redesigned iPad Pro and tell
the M3 model next year in 2024 so with
that said I believe the big new secret
feature will be maxafe wireless charging
on the iPad Pro which is gonna blow
people's minds and it's going to come
hand in hand with a brand new redesigned
magic keyboard for the iPad Pro with Max
save charging as well which actually
Mark German did mention that we're
getting a new redesigned magic keyboard
on Sunday's power on newsletter now the
main feature that Mark talked about was
actually a larger trackpad to address
the complaints of having a trackpad
that's way too small but I believe it's
going to be even better than that so
let's head into a bunch of Apple patents
to show off what apple is working on
let's start with this pattern that shows
off a Next Generation magic keyboard
that includes an apple pencil retainer
and charger within the actual hinge of
the magic keyboard which is really
unique and could hint at a new third gen
pencil that could be potentially smaller
or thinner in order to fit into the
actual hinge on top of that the patent
discusses a new 2 Double hinge design
that allows for a couple of cool new
modes like this higher elevation
position which raises the iPad Pro even
higher for ease of use as well as this
new clipboard mode that'll finally allow
you to fold the magic keyboard down to
make it perfect for apple pencil drawing
and note taking without having to take
it off and put it on the table like you
have to do because this magic keyboard
does not fold down there was also
another pattern that mentioned a new
magic keyboard that includes multiple
roller hinges that provide greater
angular options than what we have right
now because this is pretty limited it
doesn't go up that high so the new
angular hinges would fix the issue of
limited display angles on the current
model but now let's get into the most
exciting aspect we have this patent that
talks about apple pudding inductive
charging coils into the actual iPad Pro
chassis now the way Apple did this
patent was really weird because they
showed off a ton of different coils that
are meant to recharge the apple pencil
during use but that is actually a decoy
made by Apple to hide what this patent
is really meant for in the patent images
they showed off one example where
there's just a single charging coil
inside of the iPad and within the text
they mentioned that other devices such
as but not limited to smartphones and
portable media players can be
inductively charged in a similar fashion
which basically confirms that this
patent covers actual Mac safe charging
and reverse wireless charging going even
further Apple was granted this patent
which covers a Macbook reverse wireless
charging multiple devices including
iPhones Apple watches and an iPad using
multiple sets of charging coils which
proves reverse wireless charging but I
believe this was also a decoy patent
actually intended for it to be used with
an iPad Pro instead of the MacBook
because of this wording the first
electronic device is a device selected
from a group consisting of a mobile
phone smartphone tablet notebook and a
protective case which basically means
that it covers Max save charging within
a tablet and within a protective case
like the magic keyboard and for even
further Evidence Apple recently won a
patent for a cover accessory with an
integrated inductive power receiving
assembly and when you look closely at
the patent images it shows magnetic
alignment structures and a coil in the
middle which is literally Apple's
macsafe wireless charging system being
built into a foldable removable case
like the magic keyboard so yes I believe
that the second gen magic keyboard will
itself support Max safe so that you can
charge charge the iPad Pro using a Max
save charging puck magnetically attached
to the back of the keyboard which will
pass through charge the iPad Pro which
itself will also have magsafe built in
but I also believe you'll be able to
reverse Wireless charge accessories like
an iPhone or airpods case on the back of
the magic keyboard through the iPad Pro
which will require two sets of coils
inside the new keyboard case and guess
what patent Apple filed for this one
showing off a new version of their magic
keyboard case that will be able to
recharge an iPhone Apple watch airpods
and more as you can see this patent
shows a magic keyboard with not one but
two charging coils built in with a
really weird looking design but don't
mind that because it specifically says
this is a Utility Patent and not a
design patent so the actual look will
likely be dramatically different Apple
just makes it look weird as a decoy but
the main point of this patent is that
there will be magnets used to hold other
accessories in place which again is
literally Mac safe and it mentions that
wireless power can be both transmitted
and received from the host device to the
keyboard and then to the accessories
thanks to the use of two coils so one
coil is going to be connected to the
iPad Pro directly and then the other one
is going to be used for reverse wireless
charging and for receiving power from
the max save charging puck so with all
that said I believe that's enough
evidence to prove that this new second
gen magic keyboard will come with Max
save charging hinting at the iPad Pro
coming with it as well so because of all
of that I think this new 2000 so because
so because of all of that I think this
new 2024 iPad Pro is the one that
everybody should be waiting for and if
you three subscribe above and check out
one of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]